euh du coup je suis intérimaire d'accord
intérimaire dans tout d'accord dans tous
les cas après là en ce moment j'étais en
gestion commerciale d'accord
parce que ouais on rigole on rigole mais
moi je pleure derrière bien sûr donc je
gagne on va dire 900 €
chez
entre 500 et 600 euros de facture sans
compter la crèche de mon fils que je
paye pour aller bosser vous êtes séparés
je suis séparé je l'élève depuis sa
naissance
bah forcément c'est dur parce que au
début je m'en sortais je veux dire je
pouvais lui offrir les choses qu'un
enfant normal a besoin les couches tout
ça mais bah forcément le prix augmente
les factures d'électricité ça augmente
je me suis vu doubler ma facture de gaz
et de chauffage là cet hiver donc c'est
à dire que moi avant
toute seule je vais on va dire
j'arrivais à m'en sortir avec un enfant
au début j'arrive à m'en sortir même son
ex copain mais là c'est devenu vraiment
de plus en plus dur là avec la facture
de gaz avec des électricité qui a
augmenté doublé c'est-à-dire que là moi
en plus j'ai suivi
l'espèce de réforme dans la con là de le
chauffage à 19 mon fils a été
hospitalisé pour une pneumonie donc moi
j'ai vu mon fils mon fils branché dans
un hôpital
pas savoir s'il allait faire un arrêt
respiratoire à me dire que chez moi dans
sa chambre quand il faisait 19 dans le
salon il faisait 14 ans la sienne bien
sûr il y a un moment donné où les
couches ça coûte la peau du cul c'est le
lait c'est pareil j'ai allé été pendant
un moment mais à un moment donné
forcément on arrête parce que avec le
travail tout ça c'est pas possible
je veux dire il y a un moment donné il
faut se rendre compte que nous enfin moi
dans mon cas on est des millions bien
sûr et des millions
représentez énormément de personnes qui
nous regardent ouais mais en attendant
on nous écoute pas
on est là essayez de trouver des
solutions je sais que vous aujourd'hui
vous dites aujourd'hui moi je peux pas
je peux pas manger tous les jours en
tout cas tous les repas
ça me fait mal au cœur de le dire j'ai
même honte en fait non mais il faut pas
avoir honte dans ma famille mes amis ils
savent pas forcément mais ouais moi je
me prive en fait je sais Manon
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait votre
témoignage ce soir on s'est dit que
c'était le le bon moment parce que les
Français sont pas non plus dans la rue
pour rien forcément voilà ils sont ils
sont pas ils sont pas complètement fous
et aujourd'hui il y a des personnes qui
sont en détresse énorme et quand on voit
l'inflation et aujourd'hui avec 900
euros par mois avec un enfant comme vous
voulez même sans enfant d'ailleurs c'est
pas possible c'est impossible c'est
impossible produit de première nécessité
c'est ça qui a augmenté j'ai vu tout à
l'heure on avait vu le les prix les
pourcentage mais c'est impossible c'est
impossible c'est impossible aujourd'hui
vous privilégiez bien entendu votre
votre enfant et c'est bien normal et
aujourd'hui elle elle peut pas manger à
tous les repas Manon et elle travaille
elle veut travailler elle a envie de
travailler elle a envie de se battre
boulot je
le jour j'ai failli trouver un emploi de
nuit c'est ma mère qui m'a résonné en
disant Manon il y a un moment donné tu
vas pas pouvoir travailler le jour être
maman et travailler la nuit c'est pas
possible à péter un câble bien sûr là je
l'ai écouté vous avez quand même
bah c'est j'ai la page on va dire de
base donc l'essence 75 € et après
c'est 175 euros c'est tout cumuler après
si j'arrive à faire des bons mois
d'intérim parce que c'est pareil je suis
qu'à mi-temps parce que forcément bah je
peux pas faire garder mon truc tous les
jours vous allez vous allez tout
l'argent que vous allez gagner vous
allez le donner pour une crèche
alors c'est mon fils aussi donc il y a
un moment donné où il faut aussi que je
vois mon fils grandir et en fait j'ai
envie de pouvoir cumuler les deux
c'est-à-dire travailler parce que je
supporte pas rien faire bien sûr et
parce qu'il faut gagner de l'argent et
parce que je suis pour
pour ce système aussi enfin je veux dire
je j'ai envie de vivre aussi en fait et
j'ai envie de voir mon fils grandir je
l'ai pas fait pour qu'il soit élevé
pendant des années par quelqu'un alors
que c'est mon rôle
mais c'est pas possible donc en fait on
est dans un [__] de cercle vicieux
exactement où je perds mon rôle de
parents de maman aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions pour des ce
que des personnes comme Manon il y en a
plein c'est pour ça on tient ces
témoignages on a très souvent dans
l'émission on sait que vous êtes très
sensible à ce genre de témoignages mais
un moment il faut que on a fait des
émissions on a fait des choses mais à un
moment il faut que ça bouge parce que ça
c'est pas l'impression que ça bouge
énormément et il y a urgence Manon elle
fait comment elle veut travailler elle
peut pas elle peut pas elle peut pas
cumuler elle peut pas cumuler de deux
emplois
quand il quand il peut mais
on va dire que non la plupart du temps
là c'est moi qui qui suis tout seul mais
ouais non c'est pas possible moi
j'aimerais savoir Macron quand il dort
dans son lit ça va il pense pas à moi
Manon Philippot avec mon petit garçon
James de 2 ans non il s'en fout il dort
bien avec sa femme et à son petit
chauffage ses petits chaussons quand ils
sortent de son lit moi j'ai pas tout ça
moi je me caille le cul quand je me lève
à 7h du matin bien sûr
moi j'aimerais savoir quels vont être
les solutions comme qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire en fait là je fais quoi
j'y pense je me dis à mon déchets
ils vont pouvoir trouver d'autres
solutions avant parce que si on peut pas
faire un discours que j'entends tous les
jours et des gens qui disent mais on va
se [__] en l'air un moment il faut
qu'il faut que ça bouge il faut que ça
bouge vite parce que moi à 4h du matin
je suis encore en train de réfléchir
dans mon lit je me dis [__] je vais
faire comment demain
son pantalon est trop petit faut que
j'en rachète à la crèche ils m'ont dit
que ses chaussures ils étaient trop
petites je fais quoi en fait comment on
fait
j'avais proposé un truc moi pour les
j'avais dit un c'est limite un prêt oui
qu'on qu'on ferait je pense que j'en
fais partie voilà et qu'on ferait à
l'étape mais pour ce qu'en ce moment et
voilà il y a des problèmes de 2023 et
Ukraine et à la limite il y a la guerre
il y a tout son bois tout ce qui se
passe l'inflation et cetera et on voit
des gens qui souffrent peut-être pour
les aider peut-être faire un super impôt
une année et peut-être l'année d'après
voilà qui qui nous rend de l'argent les
limites c'est un espèce de près
mais c'est ça je pense que tout le monde
serait pour vraiment mais je rigole pas
non mais c'est vrai et je pense qu'il
faut prendre moi je vous dis la vérité
je vous dis franchement on prend les le
les les 100000 plus riches de France
avec 100000 plus riches de France et on
leur dit bah voilà vous allez donner en
plus cette année vous allez donner je
sais pas moi je dis une connerie hein
peut-être je vous dis une énorme
connerie peut-être que là je vais faire
le calcul je sais même pas combien ça
fait peut-être vous allez donner je dis
n'importe quoi je sais pas moi 500000
euros
une connerie dans peu après peut-être
qu'on peut trouver des idées avec les
boîtes des grosses boîtes également
parce que les grosses boîtes aujourd'hui
c'est plus facile de donner avec les
boîtes peuvent donner ils peuvent
essayer d'arranger c'est à dire que les
grosses boîtes aussi peuvent donner
peut-être un million d'euros par an en
ce moment pour l'année 2023 d'un point
en plus bien sûr si vous prenez les plus
grandes boîtes à un moment ça va faire
de l'argent qu'on donnerait à des gens
pour les aider et pour voilà je sais pas
c'est une idée peut-être c'est peut-être
c'est complètement con mais peut-être
que l'année d'après il récupérait cet
argent mais voilà aujourd'hui il faut
trouver des solutions et des solutions
elles sont aussi il faut qu'il trouve
des solutions aussi pour les grandes
entreprises les grandes entreprises
elles disent on va donner voilà et on
voilà c'est c'est qui qu'ils aient
peut-être pour l'emploi derrière voilà
que celui qui donne il va il va avoir
moins de charge sur les emplois qui va
qui va créer ou qui va qui va factoriser
les gens qui vont employer non mais
voilà je vous dis c'est c'est
aujourd'hui on peut il faut trouver des
solutions et elles sont urgentes